it's the new Ellis Island hundreds of
migrants flood into New York City's
Roosevelt Hotel there's long lines of
migrants mostly men from Africa are now
often seen outside the storied locations
and this is what people are not digging
people start to notice they go what's
going on starting to look a little third
world
but they don't they whisper that they
don't say it loudly they go I just I
you know I'm I try to understand
you know these poor people I I feel
sorry for them there's lots of
restaurants in Manhattan right now which
is a white woman with a glass of wine
going I think this is horrible what's
happening to these people but I just
don't know what good it is having them
stand outside of this hotel up my block
I don't know how does it help them